okay um we begin this hour with a new
Memoir from actor Tom Felton best known
as Harry Potter character Draco Malfoy
the books takes fans inside the iconic
franchise
[Applause]
oh you silly creature
dude man just killed me calm down it's
just a scratch
and Beyond the wand love that title by
the way Felton writes lovingly about the
late Robbie Coltrane who played Hagrid
and died last week quote he had a good
dose of Hagrid in him The Big Friendly
Giant who never lost sight of what was
important in life first on CBS morning's
Anthony Mason met up with Felton in
London to talk about his new book that
is out today and the lessons he's
learned along the way
your theater is right up here yes it
couldn't really be more uh Central to
the madness and Chaos of London in
London's Piccadilly Circus this summer
Tom Felton the actor best known for his
work in the Harry Potter films
was making his West End debut your name
up in lights
it's still surreal now to be honest with
you uh it's a pinch me moment every
morning it's pretty cool it doesn't get
old Felton was co-starring in the hit
mystery 222 a ghost story If ghosts
exist why are there absolutely loads of
them
he's been acting since he was age nine
Landing rolls in the borrowers if you
don't have a father we have a map and
Anna and the King
[Applause]
I was born enthusiastic rather than
talented Felton writes in his new Memoir
beyond the wand Harry Potter has come to
Hogwarts at age 12 that enthusiasm
landed him the role that would change
his life Draco Malfoy how early on did
you realize how long this was going to
go for
if none of us did Scared Potter over the
next 10 years in all eight Harry Potter
films Felton played Draco Malfoy
Harry's sneering Nemesis at Hogwarts
draco's fabulous sneer yes how did you
develop that draco's snare really comes
from my grandfather his grandfather had
a cameo as a wizard in the first film he
was also Felton's chaperone so he sort
of developed this idea uh in the mirror
with me one day sort of always always
constantly looking down your nose at
everything slightly
and then the tiny hint of a flared
nostril and then a tiny hint of a smile
ah come to see the show you do like
they're on screen animosity Felton was
close with his castmates especially Emma
Watson we've always had a sort of
strange love together not in the
romantic way that some people would like
to think
um how would you describe it then well
best of friends yeah people that speak
the same language similar sense of humor
she's got a wicked sense of humor no the
legendary older actors in the films
however Felton often found intimidating
Ray fines who played the Demonic
Voldemort had an otherness Felton says
that set him apart from everyone else on
set it also when in full
y mode if you will he's incredibly fluid
and flowing and you never quite know
where he's gonna go next which is
quite frightening to be honest
[Applause]
in the climactic scene of the last film
Draco had to walk towards Voldemort
done Draco
well done
and then he hugged you that's when
that's when the hug happened yeah and
then he didn't know he was going to do
that no idea in my head I'm going what
is he doing yeah incredibly awkward
um but also chilling
don't touch anything Draco
Milton Jason Isaacs who played draco's
father could be almost as frightening he
could actually switch into character
like that yeah he was smiling and lovely
and being Jason and the moment they said
the words action he just turned and
gripped me for for the first time as
Lucius and I was I was terrified
immediately what did I say you still
called Jason Isaac's dad
occasionally I do
in fact I'm very excited he's coming to
see the play um tonight oh wow yes so
he's he's actually flown back from
filming just to see it he's a very proud
father
he posted their reunion on social media
as he was wrapping up 17 weeks on stage
Felton reflected on his toughest
farewell the end of Harry Potter the
last day was hard wasn't it yes it was a
very Bittersweet goodbye I can't I can't
drive past the Eastern Studios without
you can't no I can barely talk about it
really yeah
there's a
it was our second home after a decade of
playing Draco Felton moved to Los
Angeles in 2012. he loved auditioning
for new roles don't get me wrong you go
into a panic spiral every time
um but you prove to yourself that I
can't eat this don't you know food when
you see it he landed Parts in Rise of
the Planet of the Apes
and From the Rough
distance all punishment but seduced by
the LA lifestyle he began drinking
heavily I was hiding from something he
writes in beyond the wand myself perhaps
friends finally staged an intervention
you were angry at that moment
yes I was furious at the time my brother
said sometimes you need to have a
breakdown before a breakthrough happens
um so something the wheels needed to
come off somehow a little bit did you
feel like the wheels would come off
in that moment definitely because I
couldn't see really what they were
talking about but his lawyer's words
would get through to him what did he say
he said something along the lines of
Tom I think this is the 12th
intervention that I've been to and
six of those are dead don't be the
seventh yeah
that kind of hit me Felton agreed to go
to rehab but then one night he broke out
he ended up just walking down the beach
yeah
a lot clicked when I managed to get down
to the water what clicked
that I needed that I needed help and I
was willing to accept it Tom Felton
eventually returned to London where he's
been thriving and Harry Potter is still
a big part of his life you're amazed
that this is actually bigger now than it
was then
it's incredible most fans who say hello
to me or shout Drake Over whatever
they weren't born when the first films
were being made is it important for you
to keep saying thank you yes the Potter
fan flame is not going anywhere anytime
soon and I'm I'm the first one to
to celebrate that and be very grateful
Anthony you do it again um just like the
Harry Potter films this sit down was an
emotional roller coaster yeah it's it's
well it's interesting he's that part you
know where he talks about you know the
intervention at the end it comes at the
end of the book and it kind of comes out
of nowhere I have to say I certainly
wasn't expected and I didn't know it
about him one of the things it was also
you you walk in the Piccadilly Circus in
London and and you hear like all of a
sudden you know everybody sees it they
go crazy and recognizes them and we just
got him inside the theater in time
before he was like mobbed right and this
is what he has to deal with he I didn't
realize this but he actually auditioned
for Harry and Veron Weasley on camera uh
a couple of times he told me hardcore
Potter fans probably know that but uh
that was news to me uh it you know it's
obvious it's still a huge part of his
life yeah and you can see you can still
see the emotion on his face I love when
Jay he said Jason's coming to see the
place yeah the way that his face was so
high
he was really touched because he came I
think he flew in literally just to see
him which was really sweet and when he
was talking about realizing that he was
in trouble that he needed help no it's
almost like it was hard for him to say
it but then he's he he says that yeah
well what was really clear was at the
time he didn't know he needed help he
didn't know it but that was good Anthony
yeah all right guys really powerful got
my hair Potter glasses on
Tony I didn't want to say it but I'm
glad you did yours as well you know what
I was thinking that too I'm Larry
Pottery next time you're